uh now on those strikes let's start with
the strikes the rmt says it will bring
the country to a standstill in the most
widespread war count for decades
starting on tuesday now that of course
as the uk's airports and airlines remain
in chaos and staff shortages lead to
hundreds of flight cancellations and
huge delays it really does add to that
sense of a looming summit of travel
misery problematic of course for the
transport secretary grant shaps who
joins us now thank you very much for
being uh with us mr shap so we now know
that next week's strikes will go ahead
what is the impact going to be
i think it's a huge mistake um
unfortunately uh the unions mick lynch
the rmt have been gunning for this
strike throughout um they back in april
they called the strike on the false
pretence with their members uh of taking
themselves off the pay freeze which of
course the whole of the public services
had uh for the past couple of years that
pay freeze was coming to an end anyway
the strikes are completely unnecessary
it's going to inconvenience millions of
people students doing their gcses and a
levels 17 different public exams in fact
people trying to get hospitals to try to
get to operations perhaps that have been
postponed during coronavirus it is
disastrous uh and it's no way um to
behave on the railway there's no
advantage uh to this i know that nick
lynch says he's quote nostalgic for
union power but this is no way to behave
uh you say there that you know they were
wrongly uh saying that there's going to
be a pay freeze but at the same time do
you not have any sympathy for workers
who are being hit by a massive cost of
living crisis and if you look at the
reports uh my understanding from these
reports seems to be that the pay offer
is around 2.5 percent inflation is
projected to hit 11 this year
people wagers are not going to keep up
are they i'm very i'm very concerned for
everybody's
incomes and people who won't be able to
get to work as well next week but let me
just put this in context the railway has
had 16 billion pounds that's 600 pounds
per household in this country in
emergency funding to keep it going
throughout the coronavirus to make sure
that not a single employee of the
railways had to be furloughed or lost
their jobs so the taxpayer we've all
done our part
a train driver has paid on average
medium salary 59 000 pounds a nurse
thirty one thousand pounds a care worker
because you're just to come back in mr
chaps because you are uh picking just
the train drivers here we know that
these strikes are not just trained
there's a lot more people on much lower
salaries than that working on the uh on
the railways aren't there to be fair but
the overall medium pay is 44 000 pounds
um so this is this is not a badly paid
industry i want people to be paid more
what we need is modernization of some
very antiquated working practices which
stretch back not just to the 70s but in
in some cases to 1919 which is
with regard to the failure to be able to
run trains on on sundays the world has
changed the hospitality market has come
back it's the one bit which has been
quite busy on the railways and we need
to change the modernize the the railways
so all we're asking for is modernization
in return uh for uh for pay and i think
that's a very reasonable thing to ask
for i think the public realize we can't
carry on putting the likes of 16 billion
pounds in that's 160 000 pounds of
support per individual a worker on the
railway uh over uh the last couple of
years we can't carry on doing that so
we've got to have a a reasonable
negotiation my big complaint is
yesterday afternoon as these
negotiations were ongoing uh mick lynch
and the rmt walked out and went to a tuc
rally instead they're gunning for this
strike i'm afraid and it's going to
inconvenience millions of brits
um just uh quickly um you say
all you want to see is modernization is
that just code for job cuts
well no i i'll give you a really good
example um
you know obviously no job is coming
hold on let me let me explain i'll give
you a really good example uh the safety
of the railway is incredibly important
obviously um at the moment it involves
people going out and walking along the
track too often which is dangerous and
i'm afraid i just recently read uh one
of the accident uh reports for somebody
who was killed on the track we i'm
afraid have have deaths every year
through this actually a train fitted
with sensors can take 70 000 images per
minute and drones can do the overhead
wires and it's far safer than sending
people on the tracks it requires
technology rather than people and so yes
we do need to reshape the workforce um
but as i say what's happening at the
moment is the unions are stopping that
modernization not making the railways
any safer what does that mean that means
job cuts doesn't it let's just talk in
plain english
reshaping
means some job cuts right we need to
reshape the railway around the needs of
the railway today
does that mean job cuts
we've been asking for voluntary and
getting voluntary uh redundancy so we
don't require
everybody in their current role but if i
can explain the way that things are set
up
sophie let me just let me just let me
finish this one point the way things are
set up in the railway at the moment is
like trying to conduct an orchestra but
you don't know whether the musicians
will uh to be able to sort of sit where
they need to sit whether they're going
to turn up whether they're going to
bring their instruments the
inflexibilities are built into the
contracts we need modernization on our
railways to be able to run them
efficiently more safely and in the
interest of passengers
so how many job cuts are you looking to
get to get
well there's already been 2 700
voluntary uh redundancies uh what we
know is that we
what i'm interested in is running an
efficient railway uh making sure we can
run the trains on time uh not uh running
railways based on old outdated practices
uh i don't know the exact uh i don't
know that is that number but what we're
looking to do is make sure the railway
runs for passengers and just to because
i see where you're going here just to
re-emphasize one thing we are expanding
our railways i'm opening lines which
were cut in the 60s and 70s under the
beaching cuts we're building new
railways in the you know the northern
powerhouse rail hs2 and elsewhere so
we're expanding our railways it's not a
question of making them smaller uh what
i'm more interested in is how to run
them properly rather than keeping
positions exactly as they were
throughout history which is not working
for our railway
okay uh now you haven't met with the rmt
since the 13th of may
they want to meet with you why won't you
meet with them
because the negotiations need to take
place with the employers those are the
people who have the power to
settle this uh mick lynch and the rmt
know this it's a stunt that at the 11th
hour they're suddenly saying they want
to meet up in fact only last month the
unions were saying they would not
negotiate with the government they would
refuse to meet as mick lynch put it with
the tory government his words as i say
they balloted for this action in april
before the pay offer was even on the
table under false pretences telling
their members that they weren't going to
get a pay rise without it which was
totally untrue and yesterday they
thought it was more important to attend
a tuc rally than carry on talking i
think it tells you everything that you
need to know about this i won't
undermine these talks uh by getting in
between the employer and the employees
the unions
okay and you say that you don't want to
undermine the talks it's not for the
government to get involved but you know
there are claims that actually the train
offering operating companies can't
negotiate fully uh because at the minute
because of the emergency um
measures agreements agree during covid
the government effectively bankrolls the
railways so you set the kind of
financial framework the caps if you like
the ceilings
under which these negotiations can take
place with that in mind should the
government not be in the talks uh if you
are the one setting the ceilings
no
it's true to say that the taxpayer is
bankrolling the the railway so that's
absolutely true to say um but the
train operating companies through
something called the rail delivery group
and network rail they have the
authorities to uh carry out the
negotiations you can't carry out them
out if the if the rmt union has left the
table to go to a rally but is it right
that the government has set the pay
ceilings
of course there's a this is no secret
there's a there's a national um pay
approach taken by the chancellor across
the uh public sector i've said that if
we can get the modernization that this
railway desperately needs and get rid of
these working practices that for example
mean that if somebody's taking a break a
20-minute break and the manager happens
to walk past and say hi bob then the
person taking the break can restart the
20 minutes from scratch because they
were interrupted
just to come so if the government is
setting the pay ceilings
it's fair that you should be involved in
the negotiations isn't it if you know
the rmt are concerned about the pace
if they're workers
no
and the trade unions know that only the
employer and the trade union can settle
this um to explain uh these talks have
been ongoing for a long time there are
about 20 different areas of detailed uh
and i had to say in some cases very
productive work going on that
modernization uh in in such levels of
detail that only an employer could
possibly have those negotiations i will
not cut across that i will not undermine
the employer's work i'm afraid this is a
stunt at the 11th hour by the union
whilst they're off holding a rally
suddenly coming forward and saying uh we
need to negotiate with the government
now even though as i said just last
month they were telling me they wouldn't
be seen dead negotiating with the uh
with the government okay the correct
thing to happen it's a point you've
already made mr chaps um next week
obviously
could be just the start of the strike so
the rmt is saying that you know they'll
be looking at potentially
more action throughout the summer as
well
if these strikes are ongoing if they
could last for days what would the
consequences be i mean we've talked
about you know the lights potentially
going out is that a possibility
no i don't think we'll see that and uh
even whilst these strikes are ongoing
we'll see uh freight being moved around
perhaps fifty percent of the normal
levels um but i would say this you know
i hear the the leadership of this quite
militant unions nostalgic for the old
type of union power they had they don't
seem to realize the world has changed
we've been through coronavirus traveling
by train was a necessity for millions of
people before
now it's optional for a lot of those
passengers who we've desperately been
trying to get back onto the railway and
things have changed people can more
often work from home the people i'm
really upset for people actually like my
daughter who need to get to their a
levels next week and students pupils
people trying to get to hospitals those
are the people who are going to suffer
actually key workers often lower paid
workers who can't do their work from
home that's who the rmt is damaging and
it's completely unacceptable
earlier this week you told railway
workers that you risk striking
yourselves out of a job um it sounds a
bit like a threat
no it's a statement of reality right the
the railways have been on this 16
billion pound life support the
equivalent roughly of the entire police
budget in the country for the year
that's how much money we put in 600
pounds per household
of course it's a reality that if we
can't get these railways modernized if
we can't get uh the kind of efficiency
that will mean that they can work on
behalf of the traveling um public then
of course it's jeopardizing the future
of the railway itself i think it's a
huge act of self-harm to go on strike at
the moment i don't believe workers are
anywhere near as militant as their
unions who are leading them up a garden
path uh they're gunning for the strike
it's completely unnecessary there's a
sensible pay deal there's a sensible i
think modernization of the railway which
would enable much more flexibility
and much more automation and much safer
railway but the unions need to
understand the world has changed and
people don't need to necessarily travel
as they did in the past which is um
unfortunate
we want people back at work as the
government's been um saying we think
it's a better environment but people
many people will be able to function
from home and the unions don't seem to
realize that people don't need the
product in quite the same way as they
once did now the government is looking
at changing some legislation around
strikes so allowing companies to cover
striking workers with agency staff also
potentially increasing the maximum
damages that businesses can claim for
illegal strikes up to a million pounds
is that correct and how quickly could it
be brought in
yeah that's correct um minimum service
levels as well which was in our
manifesto which would mean that certain
levels of service would need to be
maintained even on a strike day what you
described as agency workers coming in is
slightly incorrect what we're actually
talking about is for example if you had
somebody in an operations room at the
moment they can be looking at one screen
they won't move around to another screen
because uh the union rules forbid it as
it happens unless you make them a
payment at which point they say it's
safe and they can do it uh what we're
talking about is requiring that kind of
flexibility so it's more transferable
skills uh than it is agency work um in
this case uh and a range of other things
as i say much of which really doesn't
need to happen if we could just get to a
sensible settlement here but i'm afraid
they are gunning for this um strike as
we've seen by them walking out of the
talks yesterday to attend a rally
uh unfortunately i think therefore we
need to protect the traveling public
um i want to talk to you a bit about
what's happening at the airports as well
uh anyone who has been on holiday or
traveled recently will have seen
firsthand the chaos that is going on
um gatwick has said it's going to reduce
capacity in the summer which means more
cancelled flights are you concerned that
other
airports could do the same thing and how
long could we see this going on for
well we've certainly seen a difficult
bounce backer you'll recall both um at
easter but also at the whitson uh
holidays those those scenes uh we've
said to the aviation sector that can't
carry on uh and we have a working group
set up with them which is meeting all
the time working very closely with the
aviation sector we have a series of
different uh things that we're going to
be putting in place and ask them to do
one of which was to ask them to review
their schedules now not on the day of
the flight or the day before where they
destroy somebody's holiday but in
advance and actually i i welcome uh what
gatwick have done to sensibly look at
the schedule and see whether it could
actually be fulfilled
and give people notice now rather than
in six weeks time five weeks time which
is what they've done i think that's
smart we'll be coming forward with some
further um ideas to help alleviate and
pressure fundamentally of course it's
down to the industry they need to make
sure they employ people get them in the
right places this reminds me a lot of
the problem that we had with a shortage
of lorry uh drivers which we fixed
through 33 different measures uh that
the government and the sector brought
together uh brought forward together and
i'd like to do the same with the
aviation sector
to give you one example something we
already did which was make it easier and
faster to employ people getting through
the security referencing system um so we
made a change in the law there and some
technical changes to make it easier to
do that
and and there are more measures along
those types of lines from a government
point of view
and then from an industry point of view
things like them looking at their
schedule as they've done is very helpful
but we'll be saying more about this
actually in the coming week i'll say
more about this but we're we're watching
it like a hawk working very closely with
the aviation sector they had a stop
start two years i understand how they've
got to this position what we need to do
is fix it for uh holiday makers and
people who want to travel by air and
this summer
it feels um just look at the jobs market
a bit more widely um it feels like we're
in a strange situation where it's almost
as if the jobs market is a bit too hot
we've got 1.3 million vacancies in the
labour market the issue of course is
getting people to fill the jobs
and paul scully uh the minister uh told
sky news this week that the answer could
be trying to get people to be a bit more
productive so if they're part-time
seeing if they want to work more hours
he was talking about people who have
recalibrated what they want to do when
on furlough
do you agree with him
what i would say actually is i i think
the solution in aviation as in the rest
of the economy is actually not
dissimilar to the way that we've solved
uh or on our way to solving i should
probably say the hgv lorry crisis which
was causing so many problems you
remember even including with tankers at
the petrol pumps and we did that by
looking at the entire market for those
employees paying a little bit more
actually often that was at the at the
very heart of it making sure people were
attracted to the industry just this week
i've launched something called
generation logistics so i think those
are the types of things which help to
resolve this problem as what you
described is an incredibly tight jobs
market i did listen to your introduction
actually and you're saying oh it's a bit
like the 70s well the big difference is
unemployment was a big problem uh
certainly later in the 70s uh what we've
got now is an economy which is
unfortunately very very high levels of
employment and very low unemployment so
i do think continuously skilling people
up uh more automation
things like that help with productivity
but also just making sure that each
sector is attractive enough to go into
and if you look at baggage handlers for
example i don't think they've had the
best deals and the best packages in the
past i think we've got to make those
jobs uh worthwhile well paid
and and comfortable jobs to do a bit
more attractive uh to encourage people
to do them understood um just finally
during boris johnson's leadership
campaign uh you were
famously the man with a spreadsheet you
predicted to the number uh the number of
uh conservative mps who get it back
boris johnson's leadership campaign
during the recent confidence vote when
148 mps uh voted against boris johnson
did number 10 call on your services
again
well i did make a prediction but i have
to say actually it's a it's a
statistical prediction so in fact
that doesn't tell you was it was it
correct did you get it on the money
again i did um but but but you did get
it on the network you
so you correctly predicted 148 mps again
um
one out of five but uh but but i i
should point out it's not as useful as
it sounds it's not as good as it sounds
it's a statistical prediction rather
than a individuals who voted
specifically in one way uh or the others
i do not want to over uh play the uh the
advantage of this because most whips
want to know who was involved whereas my
outsider looking in uh version of it was
look this is the picture as as i see it
on the subject itself getting getting
getting just one out you did much better
than number 10 who was seemingly
predicting you know far less uh mps were
going to rebel than they did did you
tell boris johnson about your prediction
did you warn him
well look i'm not going to get into sort
of details of the conversation what i
was going to say though is um speaking
to even some of those who didn't support
the prime minister a couple of weeks ago
which i've done some of the some of the
the names which would be most
recognizable with people who've been
critical everyone now is in the mood of
let's give the prime minister the
opportunity the space the time to uh
make sure that he can carry on with some
of the uh work that he's doing we just
saw him in kiev a couple of days ago
and as president zielinski um says where
britain goes other others follow with
regard to the war in ukraine i think
he's showing great international
leadership there he's going to help us
get through these challenges that we're
facing at home including um things like
um cost of living and some of the things
we've been doing on the railways prior
to the strikes like making sure that we
we have offers available for people to
buy to attract people back to the
railways through the for the sale and
and many many other things high
employment levels these are the things
which really matter to people so you
know i just think uh i i agree with some
with some of those who didn't support
the prime minister we need to give uh
the opportunity uh for this government
to do what it was elected to do
notwithstanding that it had two years of
a huge uh health crisis to deal with as
well and looking back on that the prime
minister got us the injections first the
jabs first he got us out of lockdown
first in the world and those things are
things that this prime minister achieve
above anybody else
understood we are out of time at grant
chaps uh thank you very much for being
on the programme this morning
thank you thanks so much
well we know where the government stands
on the strikes scott chaps made that
pretty clear but what about labour the
rmt has called on kirsten to stand
firmly with workers in what its general
secretary sees as a class war he's asked
which side are you on well let's try and
find out we're joined by the shadow
leveling up secretary lisa nandy thank
you very much for being with us and lisa
and andy which side are you on morning
well i'm on the side of the people who
are building and creating and driving
this country whether they work on the
railways or they're trying to use the
railways to get to work of course we
don't want strikes to have to go ahead
this week i live in the north of england
we've had 10 years of underfunding bad
management and broken promises on the
railways and we know what it means when
the railways grind to a halt but that's
why the government has got to get round
the table with the cleaners and the
ticket office staff and the station
workers to resolve this because they're
the only people who can only a few years
ago grant chaps was calling them true
heroes now he's refusing to meet them
there doesn't government hasn't lifted a
finger since march to engage in those
talks and during the pandemic they took
the right to negotiate back from the
train operating companies so they're the
only people who can resolve this and yet
they're not prepared to do it the
biggest problem that this country has is
not militant workers it's a militant
government
you say that you don't want to see the
strikes um happen but of course you know
anyone would say that you know the rmt
would say that the government would say
that it's effectively a bit kind of
meaningless and westrooting has said
previously that if he was a member of
the rmt then he would vote for
industrial action would you
well i would what i'm not a member of
the rmt what i am is a member of
parliament aspiring to form the next
government and i can tell you what we
would do in government we would get
round the table with the
workers that grant chaps was calling
true heroes only a couple of years ago
and listen seriously to their concerns
it's not payroll they've had if they
want a pay rise of 11 percent it's also
that they've got serious safety would
you agree to that what is happening on
the railways and that is exactly what
the welsh government did
that the reason that you haven't got
strikes in wales and you have got
strikes in england is because in wales
you've got a labour government and in
england you've got a tory government
it's not about whether workers go on
strike it's about the fact that we've
got a government that is currently on
strike and not doing its job
and it's pretty clear that you obviously
want the government to get around the
table um and you want to see negotiation
as the way forward but i'm just trying
to kind of get to grips with
in the current situation
where your sympathies effectively are
you know what mick lynch will be talking
to in a moment he previously told me
that kierstalmer hasn't made it clear
that he's on the side of the workers if
we just get this bland democratic party
sitting in the center of politics taking
their instructions off the daily mail to
some extent not getting behind workers
struggles you have to ask yourself why
do they call themselves the labour party
what do you say to that
well what i'd say to that is that i want
a government that actually delivers for
all of its working people these are the
people who built this country who kept
us going during the pandemic whether
they work in the private sector and are
trying to get to work on the railways or
work in the public sector trying to help
people get to work on the railways i
want a government that delivers and that
is what labour stands for this
government stands against all of those
people only this weekend they were
briefing out to the media that they'd
had a good week a wedge week they were
calling it because presumably they've
been able to pick worker against worker
which is how they plan to maintain
themselves in power i'm calling it out
because grant chaps has got some
brassneck to come on your program when
this government is presiding over
soaring inflation rates the highest in
30 years and has no plan to tackle the
cost of living they've dragged their
feet on it for months and they've got no
plan to get growth back into the economy
this is a government that in 2019 came
to power on a promise to level up and
instead what they've presided over
is absolute chaos chaos at the ports
chaos on the railways chaos at airports
chaos everywhere you go and that is
because this is a government that is not
doing its job
uh talking to grant shops earlier just
specifically talking about the strike
says still you know the rmt want pay
risers to keep uh place with uh
inflation for many people who
pay is not gonna be rising like anything
like that that's gonna seem
like a pretty tall order he also made
the point about the amount of money that
taxpayers are currently pouring into the
railways at four-fifths of the 21
billion cost of britain's railways works
out about 600 pounds per household is it
not right that there are efficiency
savings that have to be made on the
railways as effectively fewer people use
them
well the efficiency savings that
are being driven largely actually by
frontline staff who can see where
there's waste and are trying to take
action to deal with it i don't think
it's an efficiency saving though to say
you want to take a guard off a train i'm
not sure when grunt shops last got on a
train but the railways are fast becoming
no-go areas for many many people people
with disabilities
older people people in traffic women
particularly traveling late at night you
know in the north of england we remember
this well we had uh the ira bombs in
manchester and warrington um when i was
growing up we had we've had a terrorist
attack at the manchester arena in the
face of all of that the government
should not be calling it efficiency
savings to take skilled experienced
staff off the railways who help to keep
us safe that is why his interview with
you sophie was so utterly disingenuous
because what he really knows is that the
repeated amount of cuts that he's trying
to make to the railways don't just harm
the people who work on them they harm
the travelling public as well
okay
um now kirsten has submitted his
questionnaire to durham police and so if
he's found guilty of covert rule
breaches we know that he said
that he will uh resign
according to the sunday times he's been
doing a bit of succession planning just
in case that happens not assuming that
it's going to happen but just in case
apparently telling friends i will not
let this party become a basket case
again now the times reports it's
understood that he has since met a
number of members of his shadow cabinet
with leadership ambitions and has urged
them to put campaign teams in place
has he spoken to you
there's absolute nonsense no he hasn't
and i've spoken to him twice in the last
couple of days about how we persuade
this government to lift a finger to
avert a crisis on the railways are you a
bit worried has been talking to where's
streeting and not using local government
funding
sorry sir again are you a bit worried
he's been talking to wes streeting and
not you
well no i'm not worried that he's been
talking to anybody about succession
planning because i know that he's been
talking to all of us about how we rid
this country of a government that has
held us back for the last 12 years and
finally start to deliver for working
people that that is the conversation
that we're having in the labour party at
the moment our eyes are not on the
labour party for too long we spent time
debating the labour party we care about
the country that's what we're in
politics for and that's what we're
discussing
there are you say that you know we're
all discussing about politics but there
is obviously um
discussions going on in shadow cabinet
that perhaps a little bit less favorable
um lots of reports that members of the
cheddar cabinet have been telling
kirsten would stop being so boring uh
leaking stories to the media he
apparently addressed it in shadow
cabinet
and effectively told them to stop
what is going on is that true
no we're completely focused on what is
happening in the country at the moment
because we live in it and we couldn't
care more about the fact that at the
moment you've got a lot of people not
just some people now but most people who
really can't make ends meet i can't
remember a time when people worked this
hard and then got home at the end of the
week or the month and found that they
couldn't keep their heads above water
the soaring inflation rates aren't just
causing problems for families they're
causing problems for businesses as well
and every bit of our energy is going
into not just being an opposition to
this appalling government but to being a
genuine alternative so that come the
next general election we can finally
move forwards as a country and start to
get money back into communities good
jobs back into communities money back
into people's pockets and get this
country working again
if every bit of your energy is focused
on that on becoming the alternative to
the government why haven't you got more
eye-catching policies is the problem not
that kierstan was too boring but that
your policies are a bit too boring
well i'm standing here in warwick today
at the labour local government
conference where keira and i are setting
out plans to smash up a central century
of centralization and to get power back
into local hands and into communities
where it belongs we've done it before in
government through the regional
development agencies we were able to
bring advanced manufacturing jobs to
rotherham we were able to bring wind
energy jobs to grimsby now there are
kids in grimsby who are powering the
world from the grimsby docks getting
money back into people's pockets and
money back into the local community
that's what we're going to do again it
is bold it is ambitious but it's also
not any more ambitious than people in
this country are for themselves their
families their lives and their
communities and they deserve a
government that will meet that level of
ambition this one's not going to do it
so we are
okay lisa and andy thank you uh very
much lisa nandy there well
let's continue talking about those rail
strikes now the rmt union says it will
bring the country to a standstill the
first of a number of wall counts across
the network will start on tuesday just
20 percent of the normal timetable of
services is expected to be provided and
there will be knock-on disruption for
many days well let's speak now to the
general secretary of the rmt mick lynch
thank you very much for being with us i
am very interested to get your reaction
to both of the interviews we've had this
morning but first you know for a lot of
our viewers
you are the face of the stress the
disruption that they're going to face
next week whether that is children
trying to go to exams whether it's
adults trying to get to work or hospital
appointments whether it's people
hundreds of thousands of people trying
to go to glastonbury
what would you say to them
well we don't want to be the cause of
the disruption in people's lives we want
the settlement to this dispute but we're
facing a crisis for our members we're
faced with thousands of job cuts despite
what grant chap says there's been no
guarantee that these redundancies won't
be compulsory we've seen
four or five thousand jobs already go
from the railway they've told our
maintenance staff
on rail network rail that their 3 000
jobs will go
they're going to cut back on the safety
regime they've told us that every single
booking office in britain will close
they've told us that they're going to
extend the working week from 35 hours to
40 or possibly 44 and for new entrants
that will mean lower wages so they're
actually proposing pay cuts not a pay
rise and an increase in working time on
the railway and if that's the way the
rest of the society is going to go that
you have to work more hours for less
money we've got a real crisis in this
country because it means they're trying
to restore profit in a way that makes
workers pay for that uh through their
pace pay bills and through their
wage slips and through the amount of
time they're going to spend in the
workplace at the same time though a lot
of people work more than 35 hours a week
and a lot of people are going to be
facing in fact most of it's a real terms
pay cut because of inflation are you not
asking for special treatment here no
we're not asking for special treatment
we've had pay cuts we most of our
members have not had a pay rise for two
to three years i'm talking about actual
pay cuts the reduction of salaries as
well as the losses against
the rate of inflation which has been
said is 11 at the moment so it's not
just a losing out against the cost of
living they're actually proposing to cut
pay on the railway going forward that
was a proposal to put to us by the train
operating companies on thursday and
since that time they've not invited us
to any meetings whatsoever just just to
be clear on this because the reports
that i've read uh are saying uh that the
train offering 18 companies are offering
around two point five percent there's no
offer and you uh are gunning for uh
eleven percent pay wise is that true
neither of those things is true what is
true the train operating companies have
made no offer at all right during these
talks there are two two strands of talks
network rail have got a strand which is
about half the people and the train
operators the train operators adjourn
the meeting on thursday they've not
invited us to any talks whatsoever and
they've made no offer on pay and what
they've told us is what they plan to do
and what are you looking for on pay
we're looking for a pay rise that
reflects the cost of living so what does
that mean well that's the job let's be
really clear what are you asking at the
time of the network rail pay deal that
should have been done in december
it was 7.1 percent the retail price
index let's not forget that those
members didn't get a pay rise last year
either so is that what you're looking
for that's what we that's what the cost
of living would have been at the time
these deals should have been struck so
we're going to negotiate
to see if we can get a deal that
reflects that cost of living there are a
number of ways which you can put value
into a package it's not all about
straightforward pay so we'll talk to
them constructively but they're making
offers that are nowhere near there and
for half the people in the dispute
there's no offer at all and for many of
them it's the third year where there's
no offer and no proposal now grant shaps
makes a point about the amount of
taxpayers money that is going into the
railways currently right and of course
we know through coverage that uh
taxpayers have to bankroll uh the
railways
and also less people go into the office
and so uh around 75 i think is the sort
of capacity on the railways he says you
know the government has spent uh 16
billion pounds on railways and start the
pandemic 600 pounds per household are
you not effectively asking taxpayers to
bankroll salaries we're not that 16
billion was at the the peak of kovid
when they're only three or four percent
of people traveling on the railway our
members worked through that and they the
government insisted that the railways be
kept open we worked with them on that
and that was the last time i met grant
chaps to talk about working practices
and the way that we could keep the
railway open so when they say we didn't
get furlough the reason we didn't get
furloughed is we kept working every day
every shift seven days a week the point
he's making is that actually we're
talking about taxpayers i'll come to
that so at that time there was there was
a subsidy but let's not forget during
that period these train operating
companies and the rolling stock leasing
companies and the subcontractors made
500 million pounds of profit in the
worst year for rail revenue so what
grant chaps is actually doing is
subsidizing private sector profit
dividends and shares two of the
companies that i'm dealing with in this
dispute first group and go ahead are
subject to takeover bids of billions of
pounds they're really attractive to
private sector investors and they want
to take them over because they know that
there's going to be profit even while
the railway's subsidised it's not
actually true that they have been
subsidised to that level before covid
they were subsidised by 6.4 billion and
then in the covered period they had to
add to that to keep it open because
there was no revenue and what these
trade operating companies said was if
you don't give us money for the
emergency measures we're going to give
you the keys back so that
the state can run the railway and that
would have been a more efficient way to
run it actually because that would have
saved 500 million pounds of profit
that's going out to these companies so
you can't have it both ways he's
claiming the
workers are subsidised while he's
subsidising dividends and shares
well um
do you ever worry
with the big strikes happening
that there's a risk that you're over
playing your hand grant shaps has said
and he said the program earlier that
workers shouldn't risk striking
themselves out of a job we know that the
government is looking at changing some
of the legislation around strike so that
you know it's easier for workers to come
in to cover uh striking workers also
potentially increasing the damages that
companies can get back from unions for
illegal strikes do you worry we don't
take part in illegal strikes this is a
lawful ballot conducted under this tory
government's anti-union legislation but
do you think that you might be over
playing your hand and you're basically
going to battle with the government and
there will be a backlash too well if we
don't play our hand thousands of my
members will lose their jobs railway
services will be cut back the safety
regime that has been in place for a good
deal of time will be cut back 50 percent
of the maintenance on the railway
infrastructure is scheduled to be cut so
that he can cut 3000 of our members jobs
so we have to fight this because we
haven't had any pay rises we're faced
with thousands of job cuts and they want
to rip up our terms and conditions in a
form of fire and re-hire that's internal
to the railway it's just as ruthless as
p o really but they haven't got agency
workers to come in so they're saying to
our people you have to entirely change
the way you work and if you're a new
entrant you'll have to work longer and
for less money and what they've also
thrown on the table
this week in both london underground and
the railway pension scheme is that the
pensions of our members are going to be
decimated they're going to make us
poorer not only while we're at work but
poorer in retirement and that's an
agenda that the government has got
because they want to subsidise the
private sector in this country as they
are doing in the health service which is
being consumed by the private sector as
they've done in the education service
which is being consumed by the private
sector all of which are farming subsidy
direct into their dividends and
shareholders it's pretty clear that
you're not going to back away from
strike action at sitting here it's that
is more than clear i just want three
we're available to negotiate sophie this
this not something that we didn't attend
uh negotiations yesterday which grant
chapters just said on your program is an
entire fabrication we left network rail
on friday night
around half past seven and they said to
us we are prepared to meet you on sunday
they never mentioned any negotiations on
saturday because they were going to
speak to the department for transport
about what they might be able to discuss
with us so he's like he's making it up
he's lying well he's making it up what
he's saying is untrue we didn't
attend a rally instead of negotiations
there were no negotiations scheduled and
the train operating companies have not
spoken to me or any of my officials
since thursday at lunch time
throwing forward
could we see more strikes over the
summer and and what kind of consequences
could they have grant chaps are saying
that luke fright will still be running
we're not in a situation where you know
the lights could go out is he right
well i don't want the lights to go out
nobody from my side of the situation has
said the lights will go out we know they
will run a train service using
replacement labour many of whom are
unqualified to do the work and have had
very short uh two or three hour training
programs too
multiple strikes
if there's not a settlement we will
continue our campaign
i know that the as left uh another union
is balloting their members and their
returns on july the 11th the tssa which
is largely a management union in the
railway is also balloting their members
in network rail and in many of the train
operating companies it's likely that
unite that has some engineering members
in the railway will also ballot but i
think there are going to be many unions
balloting
across the country because people can't
take it anymore we've got people who are
doing full-time jobs who are having to
take state benefits and use food banks
that is a national disgrace and grant
chaps is fairly blase about that he's
claiming that everybody on the railway
is overpaid and sitting around doing
nothing our members the median wage in
this dispute is 31 000 pounds many of
the people on strike next week are
earning as low as eighteen thousand and
typically many of them were earning in
the mid twenties you think that
full-time jobs working shifts around the
clock you think this is a class struggle
class war well there's a class aspect to
everything in the economy there are
lower paid people and there are wealthy
people in this society and what's wrong
in this society is that there is an
imbalance between the people that do the
work
to keep this country going who create
the wealth of our civilization and don't
get a fair share of that wealth because
it's going to people who are vastly
wealthy where do you think labour are
currently on this class struggle i don't
know where labour are if somebody could
tell me where labour are i'd be very
happy to hear it i think they're
triangulating between what they think is
public opinion in the likes of the daily
mail and the commentary in this country
but what they've got to do and what i
want them to do and i want kierstama to
be successful and i want him to be our
next prime minister
is con get back in contact with working
people working people are suffering
there's really poor employment practice
in this country many people are in
vulnerable jobs with low pay and he's
got to come up with a program that
identifies himself and the labour
party's policies directly with those
working people so that they can get
behind him and the trade union movement
can get fully behind him i mean we're
streeting the shadow house secretary
reportedly apologized in shadow cabinet
for saying that if he was an rmt member
he would be voting for strike action
well if he anyone was an rnt member
they'd be voting for strike action you
look at the ballot
we had 89 percent of our members do you
think that should be more comfortable
about saying that publicly that's what
they labor should be comfortable with
backing working-class people who are
struggling and one of the ways that they
can redress the imbalance is through
industrial action where negotiations
fail
what else are we to do are we to plead
are we to beg we want to bargain
for our futures we want to negotiate and
if we're not bargaining you have to beg
and i don't want any working-class
people in this country to have to beg
the employers for a decent living and
kierstarma shouldn't want that either so
if we don't have industrial action and
we don't have that
attempt to rebalance society what is it
we do do we just accept mass
redundancies and our people getting
poorer year by year which is the
situation since cameron and osborne got
elected public sector workers have been
robbed of wages whether they're in the
military the police force the health
service the care service education all
of those people are getting poorer every
year and it's this government that's
responsible for it and if kia stammer
can't find the imagination to find which
side of the equation he needs to be on
he needs to think about where the labour
party is going and i hope you can
succeed in that you say that you would
like him to be the next prime minister
do you think he's on track to be the
next prime minister well i hope so i
want a labour government i want the
labour government that can deliver
a pro-working people agenda and that
means a lot of things it means funding
the public services properly but it also
means reconfiguring our cities and our
towns so that our people can get decent
council housing it means we have a good
transport system it means we have a good
environment and the railways are a key
part of that but in many of our towns
and villages and cities people are cut
off by high transport fares by high
service costs for everything that they
do now he's got to find a way of
creating policies that address that
situation and i hope he can succeed
well he hasn't produced policies they're
in that position where they're in purdue
as they call it on policy but i think
he's got to come out with some policies
that show he's on the side of working
people okay thank you very much being on
the program uh again uh the man uh there
uh who is uh of course uh calling those
strikes next week thank you thank you
now boris johnson's ethics advisor
resigned this week after he was asked
for his view on plans that could have
broken international trade laws lord
geit has previously expressed
disappointment over the controversial
refurbishment of the prime minister's
flats and the partygate scandal but this
seemed to be the final straw now we're
gonna can talk now to the concept of mp
john penrose who offers some criticism
of the prime minister when he resigned
as his anti-corruption star just a
couple of weeks back thank you very much
for being uh with us
can you just firstly remind our viewers
on why you felt you had to resign from
your post
well mine was a little bit different
from lord guys although lord i think has
since agreed with me with his
resignation letter what i was saying was
that when the prime minister responded
to the sugree report he was urged to
come up with a reply which addressed
whether or not um the surrey report said
that he'd broken the ministerial code or
not and he was very very focused on
whether or not he broke the ministerial
code by being issued with a fixed
penalty notice if you remember by the
police didn't really address the
main
criticism in the sugray report which was
the failure of leadership that sue great
described it as the report said and of
course leadership at number 10 of the
the culture of the organization that
allowed all those parties to happen
is one of the central seven principles
of integrity and public life they're
called the nolan principles they run
like a sticker rock right the way
through the middle of the ministerial
code and it was pretty hard i thought to
conclude that the prime minister wasn't
being criticized for breaking
ministerial code and when he didn't
really address that i just thought i had
to go but i'm i'm i'm very sorry that it
came to that obviously it wasn't a
decision which i took very lightly and
but that was my reason and i think that
lord guyt actually backed it up as one
of the points he made in his letter uh
when he when he resigned a lot earlier
on this week
you say that little guy you felt backed
up that principle but to be honest i
think most people would find it a bit
more
easy to get their heads around i guess
if lord gait had resigned for the
reasons that you did and you know he he
didn't go
over the parties at number 10 or over
the flat refurbishment instead it seemed
like he decided to quit after a request
for advice about tariffs on chinese
steel i mean it doesn't really feel like
a smoking gun does it
well and that's been the sort of the big
open question you're absolutely right i
mean everyone's been reading his letter
he's since published a further
clarification but there's an awful lot
of
missing details about precisely what it
was that he was being asked to
to to opine on um and so that's still
sort of an open question which i think
people will still be looking for answers
for because no one can quite understand
why a trade deal might involve a breach
of the ministerial code or not so that's
still an outstanding and an open
question which we don't know the answer
to yet
do you think that really you know part
of the reason that he went is because of
a build-up i guess over
things like the ministerial code and how
it applies to a partygate and receiving
that fine
it it was pretty clear from his letter
yes that this was if you like the
the final straw that broke the camel's
back
and that he'd been sort of getting more
and more uncomfortable over time one of
the things that made him uncomfortable
as i said was the reason why i resigned
about a week earlier and but
ultimately we will have to see whether
or not he there's any more clarification
he can he can offer um or indeed whether
or not parliament wants to see what it
was that he was being asked to to opine
on and but we'll have to wait and see
about that one as you say still many
questions to be answered i think
now one of the reasons i was keen to
talk to you about this subject today is
because it feels as if number 10 well
they have said that they're now
reviewing
the post of ethics advisor in its
entirety do you think they might scrap
it
well i hope they won't i think that the
ethics advisor does something really
important and while it's quite possible
you do need to update and upgrade and
modernize these things every once in a
while it's quite possible to um amend it
a bit i think that if they do anything
other than strengthen it then i think
you know
they will lose a lot of credibility
and they will also
miss out on a job that urgently needs to
be done i think over the last few months
clearly demonstrate that it has to
happen so yes there are a couple of
things they could do to improve it to
strengthen it to modernize it and
scrapping which is not part of that
do you think that part of it might be
driven for the fact that
it might be quite difficult to get
anybody to do the job
well we've got two ethics advisors now
well i i think that there will be an
issue with finding somebody yes um but i
think that if they strengthen the role
i've made a couple of suggestions about
how that might happen it becomes more
doable if you make it stronger and
therefore it will become i think more
attractive to the kind of
sturdily independent high caliber person
they're going to need to have to give
the role credibility and therefore to
sort of restore the credibility in this
area of the ministerial code and of
number 10. so yes it can be done but
they'll need to strengthen it in order
to make it attractive to the right kind
of person
the right kind of person being someone
who will stand up to boris johnson is
that what you mean
yes absolutely and not just a boris
johnson that the whole point about this
role is that they need to be willing to
stand up to any prime minister um
whoever they may be boris johnson or any
of his successors over the next you know
10 20 30 years you've got to have
somebody who isn't afraid to speak truth
to power
now i just want to talk to you a little
bit about the confidence uh motion 148
mps of course voting to say they had no
confidence in the prime minister we
heard from grant shaps earlier on the
program who quite interestingly said he
predicted that number and was just worn
out in his prediction which is quite
remarkable actually but he was making
the point that he thinks now most people
want everyone to move on for the prime
minister to focus on doing the job
looking at the situation in ukraine etc
is that analysis correct or do you think
that
a significant number of conceptual mps
are still harboring those concerns about
his leadership
well i think that the
by winning the vote even though i'm sure
he would have wanted to win it but much
more handily and with a bigger margin
but by winning the vote i think the
prime minister has won himself a bit of
time um and people like me and others we
have to respect the result of that vote
we have to accept it and respect it and
and i think everybody does and that
means that the prime minister's got a
little bit of time to
you know deliver the reset that he's
already said he wants to do he knows
he's got to build some you know rebuild
some bridges if you like so he's he said
he wants to do that and i think that's
entirely the right thing for him to do
but i don't think that rebuilding
bridges will just involve ignoring the
issue because i don't think ethics works
that way i don't think that integrity
works the way i think you've got to show
that you're changing what you're doing
and you're changing how you do it in
order to address the concerns you can't
just ignore them and pretend it didn't
happen
at the melon sunday reporting today
that some mps are looking at potentially
changing the rules around confidence
motions so that another one could be
held after six months
is that correct
well i think that would be a decision
for
sigrin brady who runs the the 1922
committee which is kind of like the the
trade union if you like for for
conservative mps um and i
my guess is that what he would i think
he's actually said this publicly is that
there's not much point in changing the
rules unless it's quite likely that
another vote would come up with a
different result um so i think it would
require quite a lot of uh conservative
mps who voted in favor of the prime
minister in the last vote to come to him
privately and say look i've changed my
mind and only at that point didn't make
very much sense otherwise you're just
sort of going through
sort of party constitutional hoops for
no very good practical purpose and and
what's the point of that
but it would be uh possible to do uh if
enough conservative mps indicated that
they'd like to see another one
well at that point there's a process and
the
votes and stuff like that but yes you
could do it um but i think that uh
everyone is
playing that one quite carefully and not
wanting to sort of found the flames of
that idea just because there's not much
point um if if the reset works if the
prime minister persuades people if he
rebuilds the bridges that he said he
wants to do um then it all becomes a bit
sort of a theoretical argument i think
is the point
okay that makes sense uh thank you very
much for being on the program uh this
morning john penrose there
john penrose there well let's turn now
to the war in ukraine because prime
minister boris johnson made a second
visit to kiev this week as the
relentless fighting grinds on in the
donbass region now on this program we've
had a series of interviews with some
incredibly impressive ukrainian women
you know as the men fight it has been
really the women of ukraine leading the
political and diplomatic push and our
next guest
is certainly uh in that bracket we're
joined now live from keith by the
ukrainian mp ivana klimpos tenzatsky who
was the former vice prime minister of
the country and is now chair of the
parliamentary committee on integration
of ukraine to the eu thank you so much
for being with us
it's my pleasure thank you for having me
just
i just want to start talking about the
current situation in ukraine and it
feels like the fighting is really
intensifying in the donbass region and
what is your update on what the
situation is
yes unfortunately there is um fearful
fighting ongoing in the east of the
country and unfortunately also
bombardments of cities across the
country uh are continued by russian
federation also uh fighting is ongoing
in the northern eastern part and and
southern part of ukraine
so the situation is not getting easier
on us and that's why for us it's
extremely important that there is a
continued
stream of military support coming to
ukraine
because the urgency the quality and the
quantity of the weaponry that could be
provided by our partners is basically
critical for our ability to withheld
this um this attacks
it feels as if
much the story of the war so far has
been about ukrainian success in
repelling
forces from kiev in taking back some
territory uh more recently
are you concerned that as russia focuses
on the east of the country that
narrative might be changing
you know uh it's not about the narrative
we don't have um many options on the
table
we have to survive in this war that uh
when the aggressor has come to erase us
from the map of the world and we want to
live and want to build our country and
want to preserve our nation so
therefore we have to win
and that might require all results that
might require all our ability to fight
uh and and a lot unfortunately it
already takes a lot a lot of of
ukrainian best ukrainians lives um from
the military and also from the civilians
um so therefore um it's not about the
narrative we have to push it uh push it
against russian federation and yes
unfortunately at this particular moment
when russia has gathered all this
military capacity in the in the east of
the country uh we are losing some of the
territories and um and and they are um
staying in the at this particular moment
in the the hands of occupiers but we
hope there will be a moment
and the possibility for us to to get
those territories and people back
you're talking about uh the need for
more weapons from all supplies from the
west
what is the situation uh with suppliers
there have been some reports about
people even running out of ammunition
well the supplies are coming in and we
are extremely grateful for all those
nations that are making this effort and
that are um
also showing example to those who have
been hesitating or who have been much
slower uh on this track but at this
particular moment definitely this is
still not enough for us to have the
uh enough artillery capability enough
multiple
launch rocket systems capability to
fight back all that uh all those rockets
and artillery and tanks that that are
coming from russian federation they are
not counting the they are not counting
the munitions they they have just more
than enough while sometimes
unfortunately in some of the areas the
ratio of our weaponry is one to ten with
the russians
oh yeah that really is a pretty stark um
example there that that ratio that
you've just given to us there's been a
bit of criticism from some about some
european countries but being too slow
to show support for ukraine do you feel
that that's changed this week
with the news from the eu that you've
been given membership candidate status
and also of course the visit
to ukraine from the leaders of germany
france and italy
i think it was very important visit
of those of those leaders of the eu
and uh very important that they have
finally made up their minds uh to
support the candidacy of ukraine uh to
join the the european union however i
would um also like to to underline that
doesn't that uh that decision uh which i
think is um is totally
you know right thing to do at this
particular moment for ukrainian people
and for ukrainian state um should not
dismiss the other needs of of
of our country and those are um we call
it i call it as a major humanitarian aid
for ukraine in terms of um
actually getting weaponry unfortunately
we are not getting enough from those uh
particular states and um well like
germany has been
giving smaller weaponry and we
understand that that was already a big
change in their policy
but so far heavy weaponry does not come
really from from from that country and i
think it's a big mistake of germany
trying to kind of postpone those
decisions uh so far but i hope that
after you know chancellor schwartz and
after the the other leaders have
actually seen the
uh ruins and destruction that russians
have uh have brought
on our land near near cave uh with their
own eyes maybe that could change their
actually personal um
readiness to take the decisions on
additional weaponry for for us to
protect because we are protecting
ourselves
and how does it contrast with the uk uh
boris johnson of course made his visit
second visit to kiev this week
you know we
extremely appreciate
his visits and his real
uh very clear stance on the need to
support
ukraine by the free
uh world by free countries and we are uh
we are grateful for his leadership i
think uh to an extent maybe his visit
has a kind of balance the need to talk
and prioritize the security and and the
military assistance at this particular
moment in comparison to what the other
leaders saw the day before have been uh
talking about so we would like others to
to also um
follow the path and follow the example
of of britain in terms of britain and
the us uh in terms of helping us with
the with the weaponry
and just finally you know i've been
talking to you as a politician so far
and i'd like to kind of finish by
talking to you as a mother um
i've you know read some of your
interviews previously and i think you're
a mum of teenagers
and i just wonder how it is
for you um you know having the children
in the middle of a war
how do you parent how do you explain to
them what is going on and how do you
make them feel reassured
uh thank you for asking i think this is
probably the the most challenging part
of our jobs today so to say
um to to ensure that um that they are
getting that support that
and and that we are there for them uh
because we we cannot unfortunately spend
enough time with our kids um at all at
this particular moment when you are
preoccupied with serving the country and
you actually sometimes you have to
actually choose the
the responsibility um in front of the
country uh as a first and major option
and then and then going um going and
helping um even psychologically or you
know emotionally helping your children
but we are trying to to do that all of
us who are moms uh in uh who are in the
parliament or in the governmental
positions
uh it's tough they are
i think uh the generation of our kids
that's my feeling from what my my
daughters are telling me
uh one is 16 another is 19. um and
the this is the generation that will not
forgive russians um in
the the the destruction the death the
uh the pain that they have brought on
our land and it's not because we are
teaching uh them this it's because what
they are watching and how they are
watching
uh the situation developing and how they
are becoming
um
you know very
full
they are full of pain uh they are full
of desire to engage and to help so they
are volunteering for different things
and
and and trying to do their their least
at least something that they can do uh
their most uh to to to help also the
armed forces and that's um i think shows
also the the incredible unity of the of
the society because the society is
comprised of those little tiny bits um
and little human stories
uh that they have and
you know i hope they can come back to 2k
if they are not in cave in this
particular moment they really want to go
to to come back home uh but uh so far we
do not feel that it is safe enough for
them to be to be home so really i hope
that situation changes for you up soon
and that you know keith is safe enough
for your daughters to return
um thank you so much for talking to us
uh this week
thank you